give us a sense of why this is
particularly important and what you
expect from it yeah hello from Pyongyang
we went through where the Congress is
being held earlier this morning where
thousands of delegates from across the
country are gathering where we expect
Kim jong-un to be addressing then that's
as far as we got was outside that
Congress called we haven't been allowed
in so now we're waiting for news we're
waiting to be able to give acts to be
given access we know the economy is
something that a lot of people have been
watching on any signals on that there's
a gray market here that's developed over
the last few years middle class there's
taxis there are cars on the road
buildings going up even bottles of
Johnnie Walker that we've seen in
supermarkets here can that great market
economy be formalized somehow will the
Congress give that their blessing that's
something that a lot of people are
looking for go and what does it say
about Kim Jong Il's sense of his own
security in his position that he's
willing to have this Congress now as I
say last time was 1980 when his father
was designated the air yeah absolutely
his father Kim jong-il he pursued a
policy of military first and that
basically subjugated the party to some
degree the party and the Workers Party
Congress meant to be held every five
years he never held one Kim jong-il 1980
was when he was involved he was given a
string of titles when he took over 14
years later Kim Jong Un's making the
party center again this is about
controlling and shoring up his support
he wants to use the party to do that and
he wants to use this Congress defender a
message of strong message the people's
North Korea and also to the outside
world of course and we're gonna be
looking for noise and signals from them
about their nuclear policies also any
overtures to China they're very
important ally they depend on China for
aid but that relationship has been
fractured somewhat by the nuclear test
that we've seen over the last few months
guys John how much access are you
getting actually to this and how much
how much are you just being too allowed
behind to have access and see what's
actually going on we are everything we
do is very heavily monitored we have
minders with us one designated for each
journalist we are taken from venue to
venue were not told where we're going
we're not told when certain thing
they're happening we've been taken to a
model farm we've been taken to a
shopping mall we weren't allowed to film
in there but that's where we saw the
bottles of Johnnie Walker TV sets
Chinese clothes we saw people regular
people going about their shopping we
went to this farm we saw farmers now
they're allowed to keep up to 30% of
what they produce that the reform that's
come about they can sell that on the
open market and we've been taken to
military sites where they've talked
about their historic military legacies
but everything is very very strictly
controlled we were hoping to get into
Congress today we were kept about 200
meters far from outside the building as
approached as we got does